ah bullies they've existed since the
dawn of man making fun of other cavemens
loincloths and how they weren't the
designer lowing claws or the cool
cavemen war they always had an issue
that they couldn't get around how can I
bully someone when we're not in the same
room or a cave cave room unfortunately
modern technology has come to the rescue
today's bullies are more efficient they
can bully from afar they have all of the
power of the Internet at their disposal
it's actually kind of ironic that those
nerds that got bullied in the 80s went
on to great success inventing things
like smartphones and the internet and
now bullies use those same inventions to
start the bullying all over again huh
that sucks we need actual things that
kids can do right now to overcome
bullying a step-by-step guide luckily we
have that step-by-step guide it's called
the Survival Guide to bullying and it's
written for a real bullying survivor
lucky for you guys we have those steps
in this video it's filled with them I'm
drew Coolidge and right now get ready
we're gonna stop bullying this is
hashtag news isn't it great the
technology is everywhere nowadays but
this also means it feels like our
bullies aren't just a problem at school
anymore it's like Facebook has become
the lunchroom worse because there's no
supervision or pizza Fridays my two
favorite things
Pizza and supervision so here's my first
tip of something you can do right now to
beat cyber bully hi I'm sorry I didn't
see you there I'll scream easy blocking
out the haters you don't have to put
spoons over your eyes to block out all
the haters which is good cuz it's hard
to keep them on get rid of those spoons
now you can just actually block that so
on Facebook for example to cut out a
digital bully from your life just click
on the lock icon go to how do I stop
someone from bothering me enter the name
of the person you want to block and
click block don't be afraid to do it I
block people all the time last week add
to block my grandma of course I don't
get any likes on my post anymore but hey
at least I don't get old viral videos
constantly posted on my wall every day
grandma
no no sometimes it can feel like you
have to block everyone on your list of
friends tip number two delete your
Facebook let me sound like a death
sentence but I promise you it's really
not if people are harassing you or
making it an unpleasant experience why
keep it trust me when you quit social
media you immediately have free time to
learn something amazing like the
pitch-perfect cup song to deactivate
your Facebook click the account menu on
the top right of your Facebook page
select settings scroll over to security
on the left side now once you click
security you will see an option to
deactivate your Facebook profile
Facebook will have a clingy emotional
breakdown but just ignore for now you
can consult it later now remember you're
just deactivating it so all of your
pictures are not deleted you're not
deleting everything you're just
deactivating it which means you're not
actively on the site it's a little
Facebook vacation a vacation as no one
calls it ok so tip number three you've
maybe deactivated your Facebook or at
least block some troublemakers but
you're still getting bullied on your
phone if you have an iPhone go to the
phone app and quit contacts at the
bottom tap on the contact you want to
block scroll down to the bottom and
click block this caller if you don't
have an iPhone then you might have an
Android and the process is pretty
similar on there you can just Google how
to block people on an Android how to
block people on a flip phone how to
block people on a beeper you don't
remember those I do companies like 18 t
Verizon and Sprint all offer ways to
block unwanted callers tip number 4
lasts your business on the internet go
to reddit.com and post your story in
subreddits that provide support like
assistance advice need advice bullying
it's a great community there's thousands
of people there just waiting to help
people alike reddit youtube also has a
support community even youtube videos
about your situation could be seen by
millions of people and while it might
feel like a message in a bottle
sometimes it's a great place to find
hope ok so hopefully this advice helps
you with some bullies on the internet
what about the bullies behind that other
less watched screen real life well we
can help you with that too there's
another video we made specifically about
that right here we'll also include the
link in the description if you're
dealing with bullies online remember it
does get better you're not alone even if
you're staring at a computer screen by
yourself right now
your tribe is on the other side
of that screen check out the Survival
Guide to bullying it has so many
real-life practical tips that we just
don't have time to get to here check it
out so please subscribe to NMR for more
videos about the things you really care
about whether it's bullying or dinosaurs
or time travel or superhero movies I'm
gonna pitch that to Hollywood if you
want to keep that conversation going
use the hashtag no bullying with the
tips in that book and these two videos
we can get that much closer to making
bullying obsolete
I'm drew Coolidge and I'm gonna go
figure out how that didn't keep so
stones on his eyelids and he has a
really strong eyes and one and two and
three they feel stronger I gotta go wink
at some more people Hey
you